of the national parliaments that are
connected with us and what a greeting we are in the
midst of a dramatic crisis
a year ago the crisis began that this
crisis immediately demonstrated that
women and girls not only found themselves
in the forefront of the
emergency health response but also are  were
immediately the first victims the
social victims of a crisis that we have
not yet seen the end of
simone de beauvoir said
never forget that
a political, economic or religious crisis will be enough
for women's rights to be
called into question these rights are
not  are never acquired you will have to remain
vigilant throughout your life
this quote fits very well
with the crisis we are going through
ladies and gentlemen the cover
19 pandemic has not only consolidated the
injustices and inequalities already
present in our societies but
risks erasing decades of achievements  of the
battles of European women on the
right to work at c  onsharing
of care work autonomy in
relationships respect for the right of
one's choices in emotional relationships
covip and its crisis risk
calling all of this into question
women
's rights organizations and human rights defenders leo ng
civil society  the academic world
tell us that the measures taken by
governments to contain the spread of the
virus have
very often widened the gender gap
in terms of unemployment burden of
domestic work financial security and
personal autonomy of women in
all our countries women have been the
first to lose their jobs or to end up on
layoffs the sectors most affected
by the economic impact of the pandemic
are sectors in which there is a strong female presence
think of tourism culture
leisure catering
the majority of the workforce that
provides essential care services
of people is made up of women
women represent  76% of
healthcare personnel are exempt
86% of carers
in the European Union due to the
pandemic many women have been
forced to work part-time
stay at home to care for the children
of the elderly of people with
disabilities the sketch  of poverty in
Europe today is a mother and above all a
mother with the end of
this pandemic highlighted a
perverse trait of our economic and
social model and that is the consideration of
poverty as a fault but the pandemic has
also highlighted how much caring
for others is  essential for
society and this constitutes a
public good and above all how much that
care work
today entrusted largely to women
is in reality
everyone's responsibility and must be considered, as
I said, a public good during
confinement an even higher number
of women have  suffered violence violence
by the partner of men
within the family dimension
domestic ill in some countries only a few
women the wealthiest and most educated
have access to
sexual and reproductive health services and therefore are
deprived of the right to be treated ladies and
gentlemen we can fight this
pandemic and against the social and
economic impact it has and will have  on
people's lives only if we put
women girls at the heart
of our response we must not do it
as a tribute to a general principle
we must do it by harnessing the powers we
have that at this house the
European Parliament national parliaments and
we must do it to change  the
material living conditions of women for the better
and make women take a leap forward and not
backwards in the transition
we are building the continent that
has led the fight for
women's rights in past centuries is now called
to promote real equality  of
women as everyone's battle
that's why we have to put an end to
rhetoric and oc  care for life
first and foremost women must
be equally present in places
where recovery decisions are made
in many European countries
women lead
effective and inclusive pandemic response strategies
female leadership and participation shape
policies plans budgets  more inclusive and
is here to face this great challenge
nothing will be the same as before
we have said it many times we do not
repeat it the more we make sure that
nothing is really known as before and the
pandemic offers us great
opportunities to rethink our
goals of  build more
equal societies and we will have no
digital green transition if it is no longer fair
in terms of gender equality and
that is why in the MFF negotiations we
insisted that gender equality and the
gender dimension be
central priorities in the seven-year budget
of the  european union
a battle we won together
and now we must  lead through
a thorough
gender impact assessment and
careful monitoring in programs
in the light of this criterion
we must now also analyze the
national recovery plans in the
structured dialogue that we will have with the
European Commission and which we have
negotiated in the framework of the recovery
render silens facility  this may
seem abstract but if the recovery
takes priority over equality this
will change people's lives
women very concretely in countries
in cities in workplaces in
schools in universities in the world of
research and culture in places
where women do the work  difference between the
old world and the new world and to
which they are excluded today but this is
important but perhaps it is not enough we
need to start from
wage equality equal wage for equal
work it is a principle that is
enshrined in our treaties but in 2021
a fort still lives in society and in national legal systems  huge
unequal
pay and wages and this is no longer
acceptable president von der leyen has
pledged to introduce binding measures
into her mandate i
am glad that yesterday the
committee finally tabled a proposal
that we are now ready to look at
women's leadership essential  to
bring about change but how many
women are there for example on company boards
of directors
the directive on the presence of women
on boards of directors has been
blocked for too many years on boards
this is an anachronism that we have to
overcome and I am sure that the
European Commission will  will join the European Parliament
in defending this directive is against
the Portuguese presidency in
order to make progress on this is still
very concretely we have a duty to
establish that violence against women is a
specific crime and it is a serious crime that
must be punished everywhere in all
the union territory  and European
for this we must commit ourselves to the
ratification
by all the member states of
the union of the istanbul convention
it is not an abstract question it concerns
who we are
what we want to be and it is part of
our identity card
if we want to be an actor  a
democratic point of reference, but not
only in time to add violence
against women to the list of crimes with
a European dimension enshrined
in the Treaties so that these crimes do not
go unpunished
in any member state the fight against
poverty
the fight against food poverty
childcare is another aspect that
we must consider on which we must
commit ourselves we have asked for a guarantee
for children to allow every
girl and boy in
need to have access to the
necessary care essential services which
are a public good
we expect a proposal in this
sense and we are ready to examine it
urgently and we must also commit ourselves
more strongly  ment for the application of
the work-life balance directive
because this is an
essential binding instrument to allow the
return to work of women who
have been expelled from it at a
particular stage in their lives,
I ask that the committee commit itself
together with us to  ensure that the directive
is applied fully and by all as
you know the European Parliament has done
its part in promoting full
gender equality efforts are never
enough
but there has been a commitment and we have
done so by applying the principle according to
which for every
management appointment the shortlist of
candidates must present a
gender balance
this principle should actually
be applied by all
European and national institutions by the bodies
of the European Union that serve
the European citizens
in March 2019 our institution
passed a very clear resolution
on gender balance in the appointments
of ca  candidates for posts in the field
of economic and monetary affairs on
that occasion we invited the
governments of the member states the
european
council the council the eurogroup the commission
to actively work towards
gender balance in their
forthcoming proposals for shortlists
and  appointments we cannot accept in the
future to have shortlists of only
male candidates for the designation of positions of
responsibility ladies and gentlemen this
dramatic crisis gives us the
great opportunity to make the
European Union
a different place different from the past
to make this extraordinary
political adventure
one place more is the same for all we have
many tools many resources
we have launched many proposals in a unified way
many initiatives and all of this
is available to everyone to try to
concretely take steps
forward women girls girls must
be who must feel protagonists
not only of their life but a  also of
our lives
and above all in this moment of such a
difficult recovery of our
economies and our
society,
this I believe is the sign of a
day like today's
concreteness, pragmatism but also the
vision that must accompany us for a
space  european that is different from the
past and also much better than what
we have seen to date
thank you inception presidency only
women's light masks on gender balance
shooting members of doctors doctors who lives
bacsinszky modern and seneca
elisa is perhaps the mister
jobs for europe in  forward and a ebit
shift and life insurance co
juni transparency and non-sterile
anaunia andrew presidency that the robur
of the dead nation president's agenda
quick note keynote speech media
caterina se sa che la ru paul end the
president of accounts newell's click